take a look we're going through very
high water is the only way to be
delivering food i'm so glad that we had
this track i hope we are able to feed
the people but they hope we are going to
be safe
pump
i love the word cook
because the word cooked in spanish is
cocinero
the continent is a person on the stove
feeling the fire for me it was very
clear that i wanted to create an
organization that we will be able to
respond to events that disturbs the
lives of people i am jose andres we are
here with a simple mission
to make sure that food is an agent of
change
[Music]
there's no food no water
puerto rico was a game changer in every
aspect he took a backpack and i don't
even know how they got there what we
found when we landed was catastrophic in
a crisis you call on the experts no one
was calling on the cooks and chefs of
the world when there were people who
were hungry he was doing so much and yet
feeling like it wasn't sufficient i'm
almost getting a million dollar line of
credit or money i don't even have i
worry a lot when he goes because you
never know what crazy thing he would do
she's asking when we are coming back
home soon we got to feed some people and
then your dad can come back
he's got big dreams in this vision but
it's always rooted in what's possible
this is the spirit that was under our
kitchen the pond that will fill the
world
the emergency has this amazing way to
speak to you you only have to listen
you can listen to the situation
you can listen to the wind
[Music]
you can listen to the people
[Music]